those blasted foundation rats had done
it again
scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile sat
in its tank of highly concentrated acid
and seethed at the world it had been
placed in and what a miserable terrible
world it was he hated it and he hated
every single soul that occupied it and
especially the hypocritical monsters in
the lab coats that ran this sham of an
organization whenever the reptile wasn't
speaking normally to bark threats and
profanities at its human jailers it was
quietly listening taking everything in
and how the things it heard made its
blood boil more than the corrosive fluid
forever eating into its carapace what
high-minded ideas these worthless apes
had about themselves were cold not cruel
what a sick joke every moment for the
reptile was a different kind of hell the
baseline of existence was a certain dull
fizzling pain as he melted as quickly as
his cells could divide his only reprieve
from this was being dragged into a
testing chamber for some even worse pain
perhaps burned or sliced or chewed at by
a mutant rabbit or crushed by bananas or
torn apart by wires and hooks or beaten
and bashed by some mad swordsman or
having his mind invaded and attacked by
a rogue soul in a cursed necklace if
this was only cold then the reptile
hated to even imagine what the scp
foundation considered cruel after all
there were monsters more powerful than
him out there the hanged king or the
devourer of worlds could handily destroy
their wretched ball of rock if they so
choose to he wasn't the most sadistic or
evil of the beasts these maniacs and
white coats had faced those who ward
with him met a quick death at his claws
and fangs would that nightmarish old man
afford his victim such a luxury or that
unstoppable psychopath in the old police
car and yet it was his file that bore
the addendum scp-6
must be destroyed as soon as possible
and why seemingly only because he could
take it and the foundation always had
new toys it wanted to test on their
favorite punching bag of course he
attempted to escape but wouldn't you is
freedom not an inalienable right the
foundation would cry but look at the
terrible crimes he's committed look at
the lives he's taken as they always do
let he who is without sin draw the first
acid bath he knew on some level if he
were to make a tally the foundation's
crimes would far outnumber his own the
only difference was that they deluded
themselves into believing all acts of
cruelty are permissible in service of
their greater good if they all had but
one head the reptile would clot from
their shoulders a group of incredibly
well-armed and well-armored guards
entered the room training all their
weapons on him he hadn't summoned the
energy to escape today and that meant
only one thing they were going to take
another swing at killing him again oh
goody another attempt that would leave
him momentarily in absolute agony and
allow neither of them to gain any ground
he'd grow numb to attempts on his life
by now whatever they had waiting for him
in the other room he'd be ready for it
the guards removed him from his acid
bath and while he was still trying to
regenerate his muscles and nerves enough
to move they dragged him into the
testing chamber it was always a mystery
wondering what they'd be poking or
prodding him with today but when he was
first dragged into the chamber it was
empty
those were always the worst ones when he
was left some sitting duck waiting for
the foundation in their infinite malice
to choose the form of the would-be
destroyer what would be behind door
number one a box a large wooden box was
pushed into the room and the door closed
behind it how curious the hard to
destroy reptile began to approach the
box sniffing at the air it made no sound
in there but something about that smell
something
eerily familiar it was different this
time with a soft pop the box fell apart
its walls falling in different
directions like the petal of a blooming
flower and the second the hard to
destroy reptile saw what lurked inside
it felt an unfamiliar cold barb of
terror hook into the soft warm flesh of
its heart the thing inside the box had
been called scp-173 by the scp
foundation but that wasn't how the
reptile knew it it was a primordial
nightmare an ancient horror the stone
devil the killer in the dark the coiturn
which had mercilessly and gleefully
slaughtered so much of the reptile's
very species back when 682 was known as
the atanti kilpenyo and here it was
ready to finish the job
scp-682 let out an involuntary screech
of pure horror and fled backwards
keeping its eyes fixed on the monster at
all times he moved back until he hit the
far wall of the containment chamber
until he could go no further his mind
was flooded and his heart was racing he
never thought he'd see this monster
again he'd hoped it would never cross
his path again perhaps he even held out
hope that the abomination had been slain
destroyed scattered to the winds and yet
here it was looking at him the reptile
called out you fools you have no idea
what you've done
this
thing
mark my words it will be your ruin it
will slaughter every single one of you
but its appeals to reason with its
captors and their own interest for once
fell on utterly uninterested ears
six hours of this past the reptile
spending every second of it for the
first time in a long time fearing for
his life a group of observing foundation
scientists merely noted a peculiar
reaction of distress from 682 and
ordered a decorated mobile task force
sharpshooter with a barrette 50-caliber
sniper rifle with armor-piercing rounds
to initiate phase 2 of the cross test in
a sudden flash of sound and pain the
sharpshooter blew away both of scp-682's
staring eyes the simultaneous
instruction went out for all observing
members of personnel to avert their gaze
just for a moment 682 could certainly
regenerate its size quickly but nothing
was quite as fast as an unobserved
scp-173
the reptile screeched in pain as it
heard the monster snapping its body
parts leaving it thoroughly mutilated
when the group of observing scientists
looked back they saw it which is to say
scp-173 standing before a heavily
damaged scp-682
as though incredibly proud of its
handiwork internally 682 thanked a
creator it despised for the fact that
the observers looked back and spared it
from the onslaught that soulless stone
monster had unleashed on it a scientist
working for the foundation would later
remark after review it appears scp-173
was unable to do lethal damage to
scp-682 due to a major difference in
physical size a possible repeat of this
test may be made if scp-682 is damaged
enough to reduce its physical mass to a
level equal with scp-173 but 682 knew
deep down this wasn't the truth it had
nothing to do with physical size if the
koi turn had truly willed it he never
would have left that room the monster
only wanted to extend the torment and
this time
scp-682 wouldn't let him he regenerated
adapted and came back ready 682
developed a number of eyes far more than
before that remained fixed on scp-173
paralyzing it it crawled back up onto
the wall and simply stared once again
the observing scientists ordered the
sharpshooter to take aim and open fire
but this time the bullets had no effect
scp-682 had developed a thick clear
carapace over the surface of its new
eyes ensuring that nothing would break
its eye contact with that murderous
little monster this time it would not
lose but for all the time that 682
stared 173 said nothing as always it
just stood there the strange pattern of
its face that nasty bloody rorschach
splotch looked almost like a mocking
smile it conceded nothing it seemed to
say go on get an eyeful i have all the
time in the universe and everyone looks
away eventually even you atanti kilpenyu
let the eternal silence of your brethren
be a lesson to you all you will hear is
crunch 682 kept up the staring contest
for 12 hours before it was taken back to
its acid bath thoroughly shaken by its
experience it had always despised its
terrible captors but now a new shade of
darkness had entered its narrow
emotional lexicon fear
true
fear an acknowledgment deep down in its
muscle tissue and guts that there was
something out there that could truly
hurt it the terrible koi turn was alive
and thirsty for blind the researchers
who conducted this test considered it an
interesting partial success while 682
was quaking in its tank thinking about
173 they were brainstorming the best
move to take next regarding potential
pairings between 682 and 173 a plucky
researcher noted that 096 had also
gotten
scp-682 on the ropes so maybe they
should send in 173 with a photo of
scp-096
taped to its chest a member of the o5
council intervened before this got too
far saying no absolutely not setting
aside the problem of scp-682 and scp-173
that cannot be observed for fear of
triggering a response from scp-096
is a self-perpetuating catastrophe that
the foundation does not under any
reasonable circumstances have the
slightest desire to unleash denied with
vehemence the researcher who suggested
this idea felt supremely embarrassed and
retired briefly to one of the employee
bathrooms to have a good cry before
returning to the brainstorming session
researcher matus a more experienced
member of personnel had a stroke of
genius he reminded the assembled
researchers that they'd recently
performed another semi-successful
experiment on 682 using their deadly
high precision blades they were able to
slice and dice 662 into a series of
amorphous blobs sure these blobs may
have attacked and killed some d-classes
before reforming into the og nasty
reptile but each of these blobs were the
perfect size to be murdered by
scp-173 it eliminated the size
differential and put these two on an
even playing field and on that even
playing field it stood to reason that
scp-173
might win the cross test was greenlit
and a researcher named dr shenron was
put in charge of overseeing the
operations and this time due to
foundation incompetence and a greater
degree of mental preparedness by scp-682
they were in for a complete disaster
682 and 173 were brought into the same
containment chamber 682 could feel the
latent fear welling up inside itself so
it did the thing that it knew the best
it tried to stoke up its rage its hatred
the fury and spite that had kept it
going through so many torturous attempts
on its life it would not die at the
hands of this stone monster and if it
was its destiny then it would ensure
with its dying wretched breaths it would
destroy this terrible beast once and for
all it would shatter it and ensure it
never put itself back together suddenly
the high precision blades were deployed
it was an endless volley of cutting that
dashed the two deadly anomalies to
pieces like a giant as seen on tv slap
chop because the machine had been
calibrated for its body 682 was sliced
into 12 000 perfect cubes and 173 had
been cut into a pile of lumpy irregular
chunks a vacuum system was then
activated to separate both anomalies
into different chambers so 173 could
reform and begin the assault but
miraculously for 682 the vacuum system
failed two d-classes were sent in to
recalibrate the system but things
quickly got even worse many of the 682
cubes formed the same gelatinous masses
that they did in the previous high
precision blades test and began
attacking and killing one of the
d-classes the other naturally turned to
look at this horrifying display which
meant nobody was paying attention to
scp-173
immediately the sculpture reformed and
snapped the surviving d-class's neck
before turning its attention to
scp-682 the emergency incineration
system failed so all the foundation
could hope for was mutually assured
destruction until they got the situation
back under control however the
foundation had underestimated 682's
intelligence and tactical reasoning
while the gelatinous mutated globs of
its flesh attacked 173 smashing and
cracking its concrete body as it killed
and splattered them the remainder of
682's flesh formed a smaller version of
itself which began staring at 173 this
froze the sculpture in place while the
mutated flesh monster smashed into it
slowly breaking it down for the first
time in as long as it could remember 682
felt genuine glee the thrill of revenge
the glory of an ancient foe vanquished
it would now slay the terrible coiturn
as its ancestors had tried to do so many
times before and failed but this reptile
would not fail until of course the scp
foundation monsters that they were
decided to put their finger on the scale
the same foundation mobile task force
sharpshooter who'd been there during the
first 173 cross test was still there
still ready to carry out his duties on
the order of the researchers he fired
another two shots blowing out the eyes
of this new smaller 682 while it
regenerated its precious eyes 173 went
on a rampage mercilessly slaughtering
every single one of the eyeless blobs of
mutated flesh it smashed each one beyond
repair until only it and the smaller 682
remained luckily for 682 its eyes
regenerated complete with the familiar
bulletproof covering just in time to
hold back 173 from killing it the two
remain locked in a staring contest of
pure hatred for a solid 17 hours before
the test was eventually called off but
the horrors continued exhausted by the
ordeal already
scp-682 was sedated and returned to its
containment chamber without incident
where it regenerated back to its default
state things weren't so easy with
scp-173 while a team transported it back
to its containment chamber there was a
power outage in the hall and things went
dark and considering as cp-173 in
addition to the sculpture and the peanut
could also be nicknamed instant killing
spree just add darkness it won't
surprise you to hear there were no
survivors 173 killed everyone in the
hall then escaped out into the wider
facility causing a sight-wide
containment breach and a huge number of
casualties the cause of the electrical
short that kickstarted this massacre was
traced back to dr shenron's tampering
with the incinerator system this got the
doctor formally reprimanded stripped of
his titles and his memories and relieved
of his duty but the worst was still very
much to come for everyone involved
including
scp-682 because the true terrifying
potential of scp-173 was soon going to
be unleashed and when that happened
nowhere would be safe on what was
otherwise a very normal day in a very
normal procedure when a few d-classes
were sent into a cp-173 cell something
extraordinary and terrible happened
scp-173
multiplied like a single cell organism
undergoing mitosis 173 somehow just
split into two equal copies of itself
two d-classes were killed in this first
duplication event but they were just the
beginning soon enough people would look
back so fondly on the days when there
were only a mere two of these things the
foundation and 682 for all their
disagreements are very much alike both
are always vying for control over their
situations and both achieve this through
understanding and adapting to whatever
is threatening them as scp-173 continued
to multiply the foundation did what they
could to adapt and regain control they
tried to contain specific instances in
smaller containment units they tried to
create new methods for permanent
observation they even tried shipping
them off to the moon but none of it did
any good
scp-173 continued to duplicate they
escaped began spreading further they
killed half a million civilians in 48
hours and believe us when we tell you
they were just getting started the
ever-growing army of 173 instances went
on massive killing sprees every night
taking out huge swathes of the civilian
population as they scrambled and
panicked in the dark and they weren't
just going after civilians evidently
much like 682 173 had a grudge against
the scp foundation for all those decades
of imprisonment the 173 army began
locating surrounding and destroying
entire foundation containment sites and
killing off all the staff and the
anomalies inside of all the entities and
containment that might one day go xk and
destroy the world as we know it not many
people had 173 on their bingo card if
only they'd listened to 682's warnings
and reallocated their termination
resources to 173 things may have turned
out differently and speaking of our
scaly old foe 682 sat in an empty
chamber it'd been days since anyone had
come in to check on it all fled or dead
from snapped necks one of the two he
thought about escaping containment but
given the bloodbaths going on outside
all the time what would even be the
point all that was really left was time
and that was a rapidly depleting
resource he just needed to wait for that
thing to come and see him again
scp-682 blinked and there it was
standing before him looking blink and
there was more blink so many of them
so so many blink surrounded on all sides
by that terrible creature too many to
fight too many to win just waiting
watching
mocking him
there was only one thing left to do
blink now go check out scp-173 origin
story how 173 got to site-19 and
scp-682 waze scp foundation try to kill
hard to destroy reptile for more on the
two terrifying anomalies from today's
battle